avant bien sûr d'accueillir camille
combal alors marc-antoine le bret et
marc-antoine le bret alors c'est notre
imitateur bien sûr il va nous donner des
nouvelles des stars par exemple je crois
qu'à jean claude van damme qui a fait
plein de trucs pendant les vacances
d'été quoi joue au hockey
bonjour moi c'est bientôt le printemps
je parle plus tard cette super on
s'engueulait les vacances c'est ne rien
faire mais ne rien faire c'est déjà
faire quelque chose donc de coûter
crever la vie qu'est-ce que j'ai zéro a
été crevé le couffo gonfler ses pneus
c'est pour ça que c'est super de faire
des pompes cirées je vais faire un tour
pour réfléchir un décor c'est bon j'ai
pas de camion que je fasse un grand
écart
un cadeau c'est dit c'est le sprinteur
christophe lemaître on retrouve avec
gérard holtz oui cyril je suis
actuellement en direct du stade avec
christophe lemaitre qui vient de finir
sa course alors christophe racontez-nous
votre course
vous ne voulez pas parler christophe
bass est vrai pas des à vos marques prêt
partez donc à bronzer par contre a
commencé alors cyril pallaud chez
n'importe quoi c'est pas si arriver
n'importe quoi christophe racontez-nous
votre course à vos marques prêts partez
à bombay le lacrosse le pistolet il a
dit dubois réflexe aussi bas coûts air
au bout de cinquante bêtes s'est aperçu
que l'été arrive à la moitié et bien la
fin de la course ratée de courir parce
que c'était terminé quoi d'accord
christophe c'est un rêve qui se réalise
pour vous christophe à la chine
importera oui christophe badin symbole
c'est fini deuxième non plus c'est gagné
la médaille d'argent donc c'est
doublement super merci christophe
russian là alors qu'on annonce avoir
reçu des nouvelles
on a su qu'il était parti à la pêche
c'est gilles verdez il a fait quoi
pendant les vacances à noircir il a
juste partis en vacances avec isabelle
morini bosc a commencé à me raconter une
anecdote dans l'avion à sa première fois
que j'ai eu envie qu'un avion se crashe
et après la terminer son histoire dans
l'avion du retour
quinze jours elle a duré l'anecdote
alors j'ai souvent mal à ma france mais
moi j'ai surtout mal à ma tête
l'animateur qui travaillent le plus le
mois d'août et ça maintenant au moins il
aura ses vacances et benjamin castaldi
parce que si claude story c'est quand
même très compliqué beau josé l'on joue
à deux alain secret story c'est pâques
au cosfa gogo c'est pas compliqué ce qui
s'est passé et c'est très simple c'est
que les la blanche colombe et d'éliminer
et elle a quand même
elle est quand même resté puisqu'elle
était dans une pièce secrète
ce que les autres candidats ne savais
pas mais qui est rendue aymeric chèvres
mais pendant tout cela dans la maison
des secrets vifian a vu sa vraie mère
alors que sa mère dans le jeu et la
femme dans la vie mais pas sa mère en
vrai et c'est trahir en disant maman à
sa vraie moment où la vache - et offre
d'achat qui déplut dans l'aventuré et
dit qu'il n'a jamais vue et ont été bien
sûr se sont réunis et voilà ce fait des
petits coqs ou petit cop a dit voilà
c'est tout pour le moment tu vas cyril
c'est pas si compliqué que ça aa
alors on voit tous les hôtes du soir sur
tf1 c'est nikos aliagas
bonjour à tous ceux des causes salade
tomate audio légasse cyril cet été après
ce boys j'ai travaillé sur the boys kids
mais aussi sur un nouveau projet qui va
encore plus loin avec des candidats
toujours plus talentueux et toujours
plus jeunes the voice foetus
en fait les images des premières
auditions vrai sens du rythme quel
talent et puis cyril cadeau
supplémentaire pour tpp en exclusivité
voici une photo du plus jeune candidat
de cette nouvelle version
ça mérite une standing-ovation